the structuring assignment is a
JavaScript syntax that makes it possible
to extract data from arrays or objects
into distinct variables one thing you
can do is assign variables from objects
now here's the old way to do it if you
have this voxel variable and it's
assigned to this object where you have
XY and Z its assigned to a different
variable you can say VAR x equals box of
the x bar y equals box of that Y and VAR
z equals voxel Z but here's how you
would do it with destructuring and we're
done that's all it is for destructuring
so it's going to create these three
variables from voxel so if we comment
this out and then I'm gonna put console
log X and you can see over on the
console here so it's just a quicker and
neater way to assign values directly
from an object you can also do like this
let me copy this and paste and now we're
gonna make a slight change so this means
that we're going to get the field X from
box'll and copy the value into a we're
gonna get the field Y from voxel and
copy the value into B so I can do
console log B and you can see we have
3.6 from when we logged X and then 7.4
when we log the B 7.4 comes from up
there
so you can change the names right when
you're when you're doing this you don't
have to use the names from the original
object okay you can also assign
variables from nested objects okay
here's a nested object here we have
constant a and inside a we have start
that's assigned to this object and in
that's assigned to this object and then
here or using the structuring and here
using destructuring the variable start
is assigned to the value of a dot start
which is also an object so we're going
to go into the object start then
we're gonna take the x value and assign
that to the variable start X which is
gonna be 5 then we're gonna take the Y
value from start and assign it to the
value 4 start Y so we can console that
lock that oh but let's just change the
stage of the word nest because a is
already used previously in our program
ok now you can see at the bottom five so
the value of start X is 5 so we're
looking to start I'll look into X and
then we have 5 here just like you can
destructs your objects you can D
structure arrays so let's look at an
example of that
okay so we've assigned Q and R to this
array but it's just gonna take the first
two elements from the array and assign
that Q and R so if I run that and you
can see one two with console dot log 1 2
here and you can also access the value
of any index in an array with
destructuring by using commas to reach
the desired index so if I just add a
couple commas here and then run that
again one four so it got this it got the
one here it's skipped to its skip three
and then it got the four here you can
basically do the same thing with the
rest operator so you can use the rest
operator to reassign array elements so
I'm gonna make some quick changes to
what I had above there so I'll just run
that ran that see what console dot log
QR that's right here one and two and
then I counseled that logged rest which
is three four five what we did there was
that variables Q and R got the first and
second values of the array and then
because of the rest operators presence
this is the rest operator these three
dots the rest variable here gets the
rest of the values in the form of the
array so three four and five goes into
this rest variable and then we can
console that log it here the rest
element only works correctly as the last
variable in the list and then one more
thing a bonus didn't have it written on
there yet you can use destructuring to
pass an object as a functions parameters
so here's one way to do it you can pass
an object which would have all these
properties here would have the name age
nationality and location properties and
then you use destructuring just like we
saw before 2d structure all these
properties from the object into their
own variables but there is a different
way to do this instead of using the
destructuring line right in this
function we can take this section right
here i'm gonna copy that and we'll put
right in here I can take this out
completely now we are still passing in a
profile data object but right in the
parameter we're destructuring that
object into the different variables so
again you're only passing in one object
even though in the parameter there's all
these variable names you're just passing
in a single object that contains all
these items as properties within the
object and then you can D structure out
into the different variable names and
let's say your object has all these
properties has name age nationality
location if you only want to use the
name and the age in your function you
don't have to pass in these other items
so even though you pass in just the one
profile data object it's only only gonna
take these two properties name an age
and turn them into variables for your
function and that's destructuring thanks
for watching my name is beau Carnes
don't forget to subscribe and remember
use your code for good